DeBRINCAT MADE THE GOOD PLAY
DEFENSIVELY AND THEN TOOK THE
PUCK DOWOUT.
>> Darren: MacDERMID SHOOTS,
IN FRONTN THIS ONE ALL THE
WAY ACROSS TO MAKAR.
JOST CAN'T FIND TH
>> Brendan: WE'RE TALKING ABOU
NOW PASTRNAK LOOKING AT HI DIST
1-1 HOCKEY GAME.
IT ALSO COMES ON THE H GETS INV!
HE SCORES!YLE, A FIV IT DID.
BOSTON SCORES ON
THIS IS  THE LINE.T THE
MASK ON IT.
FINAL SEINCE
NOVEMBER 3rd.
HAVEN'T LOST IT OF PLAY.
>> Darren: AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS RUSL FOR
BOSTON.
THIS ONEO SABERS ORGANIZATION.
AGAIN ANOTHER FACE-OFF, BUT IT
WAS  SLOT.
GETS ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
SCORED!
GOODNESS.
IT IS HOP, SKIPPING AN
PUCK CAME OFF-THE-WALL AND THEN
COMES TO DeBRUSK ONCE AGAIN TO
THE FRONT. GIRARD.
THROWN INTO THE SLOT.
ZONE.
BURAKOVSKY FINDS A SHOT.
SAVE MADE.
REBOUND.N CELEBRATES.
JUST AL MINUTELANDESKOG IN 19:4.
NEXTS IT TO